a superhero role shot out of the sky a
token tough guy this network paid to
protect these are just a few stars who
made big bucks for a role they never
even played
it's no secret that movie stars get paid
an obscene amount of money for their
work between upfront deals onset perks
and box office percentages it's not
uncommon for prolific actors to earn
millions of dollars per film it's
reasonable as long as the actors are
doing their jobs and entertaining the
masses but sometimes it transpires that
an actor will receive a hefty payday and
still not appear in the project they're
getting paid for
sometimes their scenes simply end up on
the cutting room floor sometimes the
film itself doesn't come together and
sometimes a rival studio might even
bribe them to turn down an offer
whatever the case may be here are some
actors who found a way to make money
from roles despite not appearing in the
final product
over the course of eight years and six
seasons james gandolfini was best known
to audiences worldwide as the lead of
hbo's crime drama the sopranos one of
the most acclaimed and well-regarded tv
shows of all time the saga of gangsters
their families and their therapy bills
is often cited as originating the modern
era of peak tv a central part of its
success was gandolfini as tony a new
jersey mob boss who balanced a menacing
exterior with a more sensitive inner
life sounds like me all right
at the show's controversial conclusion
any other network would have considered
his casting to be a massive coup
as it turns out this nearly happened
with nbc in the office with steve carell
planning to depart the hit comedy in its
seventh season the hunt was on to find a
high-profile replacement to fill his
shoes though james spader was eventually
cast apparently gandolfini was close to
nabbing the role according to his
sopranos co-star michael imperioli the
actor was so close that hbo paid him
three million dollars to turn down the
role the reason given was so that
gandolfini could continue developing the
limited series the night of with the
network tragically it wouldn't premiere
until three years after his death it
speculated that they also wanted to
preserve the tough guy legacy of tony
soprano and were concerned that a
sillier role in the office might detract
from that the harry potter franchise is
no stranger to recent controversies
between the disappointing critical and
commercial reception of the most recent
film and author j.k rowling's
controversial statements the last thing
these spin-offs needed was one of its
primary cast members in hot water yet
that's precisely what happened with
johnny depp who had been cast as the
villainous gellert grindelwald in a
surprise cameo at the end of fantastic
beasts and where to find them he later
had his role significantly fleshed out
in the sequel unfortunately for depp
personal drama began to overshadow his
acting career in the wake of a vicious
and highly public court battle with his
ex-wife amber heard the higher-ups at
warner brothers decided that being
associated with death was more trouble
than it was worth as a result the role
of grindelwald was recast with hannibal
star mass mikkelsen for the third film
still depp managed to pocket his full 16
million dollar salary for his original
contract
and contain your emotions
with a body of work ranging from classy
oscar fair to schlocky action thrillers
and everything in between nicholas
cage's career is the stuff of legend yet
one of the actors most infamous roles
was when he never got the chance to play
this of course was the title character
of the equally legendary superman lives
it was a superhero blockbuster that
would have been helmed by tim burton
with a script by kevin smith it seemed
like a match made in comic book heaven
however the film was not to be though an
official reason was never given many
have speculated that it may have to do
with the disastrous reception of joel
schumacher's batman and robin this film
could have made parent company warner
brothers apprehensive about jumping into
another big budget movie about tights
and caves jonathan gems theorized that
the studio was somehow punishing the
filmmaker for that film's lackluster
performance the entire affair was
eventually chronicled in the documentary
the death of superman lives what
happened and though cage never got the
chance to play kal-el he did reportedly
collect a cool 20 million dollars for
his trouble check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you